Pick a door
alright there
no that's my door
pick another door
what's wrong with you
you know what you were right this is
your door
what's the matter you got a lot of bad
guys behind that door
access granted
access denied
We've got unfinished business
your sister took something from me
a virus that could wipe out half the population
and I want it back
you wanna tell me just what we're
dealing with here
It's my sister, family business
when it's the fate of the world it becomes my business
his whole thing
sounds really dodgy
look after your sister
listen I'll handle it
the only way we
survive this working together like a team
let's do this
buckle up then
whoa see the look on his face you have
no idea how long I've been waiting to do that
the music's already started
I see we can get in sick
so you guys are
being hunted by an army of mercenaries
led by a genetically enhanced soldier
look at me I'm Black Superman
pretty crazy
yeah he really is black Superman
you need to get off the grid
where?
home
my babies come home I'm sorry to bring
trouble here mama
but I need my brothers
this family is going to war we're gonna need cars and guns
mama where's all our guns
i get rid of them
that's very noble Mrs. Hobbs
were in serious trouble
that's an understatement
let's go old school
well alright
common!
we're going for a ride
tell me this is not happening
you